- Ich glaub' nicht, dass es einfach wird,
'n Kredit zu bekommen.
- Das versteh' ich nicht.
Natürlich bin ich kein reicher Mann,
aber es muss trotzdem
eine Möglichkeit geben.
- Erst einmal gibt es Kredite nur unter
bestimmten Voraussetzungen
und Konditionen.
- Die Konditionen sind mir bekannt
und damit bin ich einverstanden.
- Ja, das ist gut, jedoch muss vor allem
die Bank mit dir einverstanden sein.
- Warum soll sie mit mir
nicht einverstanden sein?
- Du kannst deine Liquidität nicht belegen,
außerdem fehlen
einkommensnachweisende Unterlagen …
- Meine Familie und ich sind
vor Krieg und Tod geflohen!
Die Unterlagen haben
wir nicht mitgenommen.
- Hey. Ich bin auf deiner Seite,
aber ich kann das System
nun mal nicht ändern.
- Was brauche ich, damit ich
einen Kredit aufnehmen kann?
Ich habe alle Unterlagen, aber in Syrien …
- Die Bank braucht eine Versicherung,
dass du lange genug in Deutschland bleibst,
um den Kredit zurückzuzahlen.
- Wie soll diese Versicherung aussehen?
Es muss eine Lösung geben.
- Die gibt's. Ich bürge für dich.
- Bürgen?
- Ja, das bedeutet, wenn du nicht zahlst,
trage ich die Verantwortung.
- Das würdest du tun?
- Was soll schon passieren?
- Danke.
- Gerne.